the biggest concern on people's minds
right now is nuclear fallout we're
predicting another similar type market
crash that's gonna be worse than 2008
the hot air out the socio-economic
shadow you are the more you are prepared
something big will happen within the
next 10 years in my gut I feel it
techies can see that future coming and
therefore they react to that future even
though hasn't arrived yet I think
Silicon Valley has largely become part
of the problem everything here is a plan
for a deteriorating situation we're in
the most tense - since World War two so
a little war how's business right now
for you well it's booming this is ron
Hubbard he builds doomsday bunkers for
the apocalypse the stuff of disaster
movies and nuclear nightmares as well
felt life they are the old-school
survivalists are preparing for just
about anything a shelter has many forms
of protection it could be a volcano
erupting it could be hurricanes in
Florida but first and foremost the
biggest concern on people's minds right
now is a nuclear fallout
like I said fallout shelters are
becoming very commonplace if the
president gets threatened where did they
take him bunker immediately yeah why do
they take him to a bunker protection it
doesn't take a smart man to figure out
the safest place to be during most
threats is underground
it's not new to prepare for catastrophe
but today there's a new kind of prepper
the Silicon Valley elite and they
believe they're preparing for a doomsday
scenario of their own making with
automation setting up the economy to
crash under the weight of global debt
most of the people who are you know on
board this wagon are professionals so
they're doctors the lawyers they're tech
executives this is a very mainstream
phenomenon it's just not talked about in
the mainstream Adam Taggart gave up his
Silicon Valley lifestyle as a VP for
Yahoo to prepare for a new world he sees
as inevitable with changes so drastic
they are hard to imagine the next 20
years are going to look completely
unlike the last 20 years and the reason
for that many different potential
threats are challenges to our way of
life if you will we look at them in
three areas in the economy and our
energy systems and in the environment
now his main business is advising people
on how to prepare for collapse and many
of his clients are Silicon Valley's
wealthiest those with the money and I
realized this is the point zero zero one
percent we're talking about but are
buying retreat properties either here in
America or internationally and I think
that got people's attention of all right
these are legit smart people what do
they know that we don't know
[Music]
while the tech guys are most focused on
sustaining quality of life after a
collapse traditional Preppers are more
concerned about the actual days of
disaster a guns and bunkers moment when
society breaks down and every man must
fend for himself now this is a natural
outlet shelter under construction let me
show you the way it works okay you
actually would come down the staircase
into this room here this is called the
mudroom or the decontamination room you
could put the corpse in here because
they're gonna develop methane gas and
then you can let it let it leak out here
like really dark scenarios you gotta
consider I know it sounds creepy and it
sounds bad but you got to live with
reality this isn't a toy ron has been
building bunkers for years but it's only
recently that he started selling to the
tech guys if you have the money you have
a bunker it's just a fact of life now
those who have money have bunkers the
techies are buying bunkers and guns it's
just the reason behind it that seems to
be different I think the type of
stereotypical tinfoil hat doomsday
prepper type guy that you're mentioning
you know I think he's doing it from a
very different point of view it's almost
a non-emotional decision it's almost
just sort of a Vulcan choice of hey the
the data is telling me this and so
therefore a prudent empiricist like
myself would take these steps Ron took
us to the home of a client under the
condition that we keep the location
secret and not reveal the name of the
owner
there's your bunker I'm just sitting the
couch and watch TV as the world's going
to hell in a handbasket it's not a bad
way to write out the apocalypse we got
powdered eggs right here that's a whole
lot of powdered eggs they're back up let
me show you something here underneath
this floor here is his storage
okay this is one of the smaller bunkers
Ron says he's never been allowed to film
in larger bunkers that he builds for his
wealthiest clients those people aren't
gonna let me go and film in their
backyard why not no the money doesn't
mean nothing to them but their security
at us they're more secret about their
shelter than they are about their bank
accounts they don't want people to know
that they have it I mean it doesn't
matter that they may be spent two three
four hundred thousand dollars on their
bunker that is their family's security
the secretive nature of prepping makes
collecting data on the movement nearly
impossible but the ward in Silicon
Valley is that some secret doomsday
retreats cost well into the millions so
I'm a Antonio Garcia Martinez I am
former startup founder former Facebook
product manager and Twitter advisor and
now I'm just a bum living on this boat
and prepping for our future after he
bailed on Silicon Valley
Antonio bought property on a Pacific
Northwest Islands he currently lives on
a sailboat due in part to fears of an
economic collapse and at some point of
all the cabin electricity solar panels
and all the basics of living in a
northwestern forest on you know a few
acres of their food generators well
we're getting there we're gonna we're
gonna we're playing definitely guns yeah
definitely some gas definitely
generators lots of those one of
Antonio's biggest concerns is automation
and what that will do to the economy
when I started talking like normal
people like people in the voting world
the car you know where people outside
attack right and they tell me what they
do and every single time I could think
of some startup or Y Combinator company
that basically is working madly to code
them out of a job like literally almost
every normal job that I can hear about
ready to go yeah no that's goods
concerning yeah it's kind of terrifying
yeah most humans again most humans just
won't have any salable labor in a few
years it's hard not to wonder what
people will do for a living if so many
jobs become automated so quickly I think
techies can see that feature coming and
therefore they they react to that
feature even though it hasn't arrived
yet
it's 100% fatal there is no cure we're
bugging out to the cabin techies have
long been at the polar opposite of
prepping a guns and bunkers culture
popularized by TV shows like national
Geographics doomsday preppers Braxton's
Southwick and his family were featured a
few years back when I first started this
I was crazy everybody thought I was nuts
now I've got the whole neighborhood
involved all my friends everybody's
involved in it because it's become
mainstream I actually planned for
everything what are some of the things
other things you planned for my biggest
thing was a biological chemical attack
just because it was so cheap and easy
for a terrorist to get ahold of that so
I was like this with my tennis shoes my
clothes on I don't change anything
my field gloves I don't want to sound
crazy but I really think something big
will happen within the next 10 years I
really do and that's why I'm so prepared
you could feel it okay animals can feel
sense danger in America as humans I
think we're just as much as any animal
and some of us can really feel it
something's on the horizon we could feel
it we don't know what it is we can't see
it but I'm telling you in my gut I feel
it oh you can hear you pretty can hear
you pretty good I didn't expect that
[Applause]
Braxton walked us through the basics of
prepping from his extensive food storage
to the chickens in the backyard the bug
out bags he keeps for each person in his
family and the extensive Arsenal he
keeps that ready whatever is coming I
mean you guys are ready for it the
entire North Korean army oh you guys are
right now yeah hopefully those guys
back in San Francisco the worries do
include biological and nuclear attacks
though economic collapse is the top
concern and one venture capitalists told
me he's doing all he can to be prepared
do you see all this innovation
especially with automation do you see
the two leading to like a big rise in
unemployment yeah definitely I mean I'm
terrified by that you know to the point
where it's like wow like if you don't
manage this very well it's going to
cause like a new French Revolution right
it's not just a fringe idea the
president of the World Bank recently
sounded a blaring alarm about automation
accelerations and technology are
changing the landscape we estimate that
two-thirds of all jobs that currently
exist in developing countries will be
wiped out by automation the tech guys
might have different reasons for
preparing but they use techniques home
by the classic prepper so I went to talk
to the experts at the world's biggest
prepping trade show this is the Holy
Grail right here of traditional Preppers
you got everything you got your bug out
bags you got medical supplies food
renewable energy I mean anything you
could ever want guns it's right here
there was a hurricane simulator
a survivalist fashion show thanks for
jumping it's actually soft Bobby over
search dogs and this guy taught me how
to clear a room look at the attitude I'm
gonna clean out every vital organ of
this body nice slice slice and when you
get out here I'm gonna cross to the
other side
baby baby baby baby baby with a bad guy
okay don't stick your head out what
makes this unique okay so it's on the
ar-15 but rather than using five five
six it's using standard nine-millimeter
so your ammo cost is gonna be anyone's
cost things get really bad and we get
really primitive samurai sword number
one that you ought to have in your
bunker but it wasn't as crazy as I
thought it might be there were regular
people there with good ideas on how to
prepare for catastrophes
basically food starch a little bit of
fuel tools always good I got bags if
people are afraid then then they they'll
buy it but it's it's much more popular
than it used to be why do you think that
is I just think that people understand
that the world is a more uncertain place
it's not just the bunker business
noticing new clients Jeff Davis runs a
business that sells prepper supplies we
sell anything from you know a one-week
supply all the way up to a one-year
supply in every increment in between
Jeff told me he's not surprised to hear
that wealthy Californians are stocking
up when you've got something to lose you
buy insurance and our food is just
another form of insurance and so when
you've got something to lose you're
gonna prepare and try to mitigate that
that loss so you think about like well
you have enough like food you know do I
have like do I have the skills like I
took a lot of classes and things like a
wilderness survival and urban survival
martial arts and just and it's
interesting number what's fun but I took
a lot of shooting classes and martial
arts and all these things is that common
amongst like your friends other people
in the industry then my take is at the
higher up to social economics yeah I
know you are the more you know the more
you are prepared right because the more
you are aware of the potential backlash
and also the more resources you have and
so the more you think about it not only
that but the more that people are
advancing automation the more they can
see the possible consequences
Brad Peters is a senior software
engineer for Intel would you describe
yourself as a prepper yeah absolutely
these programs that you're developing
like you're fully aware these are gonna
make a lot of jobs obsolete yes that's
what I mean there's there's a flip side
to this it's it's fun to do but the the
societal impact is really above and
beyond the scope of what we do in a long
term there's lot of people without jobs
now and that leader situations like
you've described which you're actively
preparing for absolutely absolutely
many occupations are nearly certain to
disappear to automation in the near
future airline pilots and real estate
agents may be a bit more surprising than
typist or accountants what I see is a
future where you have a lot of people
trying to consume but the current
mechanism for wealth redistribution and
throughout the entire world as far as I
know is you contribute labor to get a
portion of the productivity productivity
or the product of that labor a lot of
these guys believe that unemployment to
automation
affected the recent election helping
Trump win the presidency we feel like
the 2008 market crash was just a wake-up
call and I mentioned we've sort of
papered over the problem since then in a
sense what we've done is we've just made
those problems worse and we push them
off to a future date so we're predicting
another similar type market crash just
sadly one that's gonna be worse in 2008
even as all dead in America has
skyrocketed growth simply is not the
rates needed to service that debt
something these tech guys say spells
trouble what makes you sell this and
move into a trailer and like a rural
area and the woods I don't want to be in
the neighborhood as these things go to
hell so we drove out to a 70 acre plot
of land outside Portland's Brad had only
recently started building out the
property and he walked me through some
of his plans to make it off-grid and
self sustainable
doing this sort of thing while the
economy overall is in good shape is easy
right what Amazon's are not there how do
you do that the conveniences can
disappear really quick but if you do
things a little bit in advance it's not
terribly hard I think a lot of it was
you know 2008-2009 I think honestly that
going through that that crash you know I
think it let a lot of people to slowly
like something to firm it you know in
the back of their minds about CAD what
can I do just little things here and
there to to be careful to be cautious
and take take steps got everything for
sustainability resilience you know
you're prepared for most options in
terms of like security you know if
things hit the fan is that what this is
for right here absolutely self-defense
man yeah it's not about aggressively
going out and seeking trouble but it's
about being able to defend yourself if
you need to everything here is a plan
for a deteriorating situation right
storing food having energy sources but
if people are straight up attacking let
me tell you like it's such a low
probability thing but if it happens then
yeah I mean it's it's to the extent that
a person can be the irony here is that
these guys can see their own industry
helping cause the next collapse but
without the tools to stop it they are
instead preparing to survive the
catastrophic result it's like you
motherfuckers created this whole
situation and now that the bill comes
due and the shit hits the fan right
you're just going to take off and leave
us holding the bag with this bullshit
right like what the hell like you're
supposed to sit around and sort of fix
it because that's the notion of like
some level of civic duty and that's you
know I have to say yeah that's the right
reaction to have to that that's right
if shit hits the fan of things actually
go really really really south whatever
you have because you become a target
right um at that point you you can
either defend yourself or you can
and you're just a big treasure-trove him
ultimately you have to be willing to
pull that trigger if it comes right down
to it
hey everyone this is Danny gold with AJ
plus be sure to take a look at the rest
of our dog series divided America where
we take a look at how the proper
movement is being embraced by the
Silicon Valley elite refugees leaving
America for Canada the defunding of
Planned Parenthood and the battle over
land rights in America thanks for
watching